okay this is from sarah kim's she says
hello pastor the anvil evangelicals teach
that the sabbath day was a sign for the
scientific covenant just as circumcision was
for the abrahamic covenant therefore the sabbath
is not binding today since we have rest in jesus
as it's indicated in hebrews 4. they also
refer to 2 verses 16 and 17 to claim the
seventh day sabbath is not finding today so i
guess he's asking how would you address this
i can't tell how many times i've run across
this colossians 2 16 and 17 that that hebrews 4
there's rest in jesus yes there's rest in jesus it
is rest from sin okay let's look at the sabbath as
given to the jews the sabbath was given to the
jews entrusted to the jews to be given to the
whole world but we are getting ahead of ourselves
the sabbath was introduced to adam and eve
are you with me to adam and eve genesis 2 from
verse 1 thus the heavens and the earth were
finished and all the hosts of them and the seventh
day god ended his work which he had made in
two and three of genesis chapter two now when
god presented the sabbath to adam and eve
they were the population of the world there
were no jews the population of the world was two
we don't need eight billion people to have
a population there's a population of two and
they were to replenish the earth the sabbath was
given to the world jesus is very clear jesus was
a jew but here's what he said the sabbath was made
for man that's what jesus said not man so christ
himself who was a jew the finest jew you can find
was jesus he said the sabbath was made for man now
if you l if you read the fourth commandment
i'll go through it exodus 28-11 remember the
sabbath day to keep it holy six days shalt thou
labor and do all thy work but the seventh day is
the sabbath of the lord thy god in it thou shalt
not do any work now listen to who should not work
thou not thy son not my daughter a man servant
but i made servant not a cattle nor thy stranger
that is within thy gates now the stranger
also had to be aware of sabbath keeping
but circumcision the stranger could not take part
in circumcision if in exodus 12 he could not take
part in circumcision it was reserved only for
for for jew deacon sorry he could not take part
in the uh the passover feast it was
only reserved for circumcised jews but
the sabbath was for everyone circumcised or not
you see the stranger was not a circumcised person
so he could not take part in the
passover feast exodus 12 from 44 onward
but if he was in an area where they were jews
and living in the territory he had to respect
the sabbath and so the sabbath then was universal
passover was restricted the sabbath is universal
and so the sabbath is not for the jews the
sabbath is for mankind now this business of uh
colossians 2 14 to 16 nails at the cross no what
was nails at the cross were the ceremonial laws
if you go to leviticus 23 in that chapter all
seven annual feasts are listed in leviticus 23
in the order in which they fall passover feast
of eleven bread the feast of uh first fruits
feast of weeks which the new testament calls
pentecost the feast of trumpets day of atonement
feast of tabernacles those are the seven feasts
you had four in the spring three in the fall
and they all taught the entire plan of
salvation from coming to christ passover
until you land in heaven feasts of tabernacles
now in that chapter before god gives the first
one which is passover beginning in verse
5 he mentions the sabbath in verse 3
which means he sets it aside and then he says
verse 4 these are the feasts of the lord even
the holy convocations which he shall proclaim in
this season now the sabbath has no season so long
before you get to colossians you don't even have
to get to colossians you look at the you look at
the earlier parts of the scripture which provide
guidance the sabbath has no season on the other
seven feasts not other feasts the sabbath is not a
feast the seven feasts they had seized us look at
verse five of leviticus 23 in the 14th day of the
fifth month and even is the lord's passover now
the 14th day can fall on any day of the week
like your birthday does and my birthday does
that is not the case with the sabbath it is
not seasonal and so while the seven feasts
represent the entire span of salvation the sabbath
is set aside because it is not a feast it is not a
ceremonial event it is central to the life of the
saved person when christ died all the seven feasts
ceased the sabbath did not cease that's why jesus
said when you're running in the time of trouble
he told his listeners when jerusalem would be
destroyed make sure that your flight be not on
the sabbath day and that occurred 40 years after
he died he expected them to be keeping the sabbath
and so to say that when christ died on the cross
he he crucified the sabbath how then could he
tell people 40 years later be sure your flight is
not on the sabbath day when we study the bible we
must not bring our cherished opinions to the bible
we must come with an open mind and let the bible
teach us there's a fundamental opposition
in people in one of the ten commandments a
fundamental opposition and that opposition is
the sabbath commandment that's why it'll be the
test commandment when the israelites came out of
egypt in exodus chapter 16 god tested them to see
if they'd obey him generally by testing them on
the fourth commandment the seventh commandment
by sending manna six days of the week and not on
the seventh and that commandment remains the test
commandment today it is the sign between people
and their god not just the jews between anyone
who keeps the sabbath and god and so the sabbath
is not the ceremonial feast it was separated
from the seven in leviticus 23 read verse three
and then the seventh feast begin in verse five
the sabbath is a part of god's commandments it
is no more ceremonial than thou shalt not kill
that is not ceremonial he still exists today
and required by god that we keep it all 10.
amen amen now elder skeet i
will ask the last two questions
all right um and the third one which is
not you know directly related to this topic
the next question comes from rodney smith
this was from last month it is 5 30 7 8 on
bc it's given as the time where the children
of israel were freed of babylonian captivity
this person is asking what is the exact start date
of the 70 years prophecy spoken of by jeremiah
well daniel 9 24 says 70 years are determined upon
by people the hebrew word determines cut off set
apart it is cut off from the from the 23 from
the from the 2300 day prophecy which was given
in the previous uh chapter chapter 8 of daniel
which daniel could not understand it's the only
period prior to daniel 9 24 period of time now it
began in 457 bc you see there were three decrees
issued when cyrus took over from the babylonians
in ezra chapter chapter one verse one onward
cyrus is a decree that the jews can go back in uh
chapter six darius takes over he issues the decree
that you know the temple could be rebuilt then
in chapter eight i believe another decree under
artaxerxes so we have a decree under osiris we
have one in the darius one on the other xerxes
the one under xerxes was given in 457 bc it was
the most comprehensive which allowed the jews to
re-establish themselves as a religion to follow
their laws and have the law read to them it was
the most comprehensive of the three and it was
given issued in 457 bc in the fall of that year
that's where we did so the bible says from
the going forth of the decree to restore and
to build jerusalem and to messiah the prince shall
be seven weeks and three score in two weeks so 457
is the starting date for the 2300 day prophecy it
is not connected to when the jews will physically
release under cyrus you know five cyrus conquered
i think babylon 538-537 but the beginning the 2300
day prophecy is 457 and that is conclusively
demonstrated by a careful study of the bible
amen thank you and it ended in october 22
1844 in the fall very precise amen amen